as we get closer and closer to apple's
march event we are getting new
information about the three max the
apple is going to release and today we
have some bad news the very original
first leaker of the notch for the 14 and
16 inch macbook pros just gave us new
information that the laptop that we are
expecting in the march event that has
been filed with the ecc
looks to be a base model macbook pro
that is going to retain the same 13-inch
design and screen
now personally we here at max tech have
three issues
with this leak but it could be correct
and then we also have three possible
scenarios on why and how apple would
decide to stick with this machine but
first let's go ahead and take a look at
the sleek from somebody that is close
with apple's supply chain they are
saying that we are going to get the m2
processor which is kind of what we are
expecting that's the most likely
scenario but this machine will have the
same exact display the same size
everything identical including the touch
bar yes the touch bar
and all the only change is going to be
that it will have the m2 chip now with
that m2 chip that will be an upgrade and
that will help this macbook still sell
along with the lower price of course
compared to the 14 and 16 inch macbooks
as you guys know we have not been
recommending anybody to buy the m1
macbook pro just because the macbook air
is such a nice device for 300 less msrp
and actually an even greater discount
once you factor in the amazing prices on
amazon that we have seen as low as
850 dollars now yes this macro pro does
have a fan does have a little bit more
performance especially under extended
loads but we did not think that the
extra was worth it and because of that i
think this is probably the worst selling
laptop right now so if apple goes ahead
and upgrades that processor they are not
only going to increase the performance
of the cpu just by a little bit they
will also increase the efficiency the
battery life will be even better but the
graphics is going to jump all the way to
maybe a nine and a ten core
configuration uh instead of you know the
seven and eight core options that they
have right now with that m1 chip so this
has is gonna have a little bit more
graphics performance and it definitely
is going to help out there now even
though this is a possibility our first
issue is that apple is putting a brand
new chip into a very old design that
doesn't really match up with what their
future is holding right we have mac safe
now we have more ports we have no touch
bars they gave us a full-size keyboard
in the 14 and 16-inch macbook pros with
large function keys and then this would
be them just saying hey we're gonna hold
this old design which is not our future
that seems a bit odd now the second
issue that we have is that as soon as
the macbook air that's going to be
redesigned and likely launching in the
fall comes out this is going to be the
last machine that holds this old design
it's going to make it even older and of
course that is also going to get the m2
chip as well so this would give this
laptop a usable kind of lifespan of
about six months before it just feels
even more outdated and left in the past
that will just make it irrelevant that's
gonna really tank its value and it's
just kind of an odd decision now the
third issue that we have with it is that
if apple does keep this old design they
are not going to be able to raise the
price point from its current base 1299
up to say 1399 or 1499 which is what we
expected if they will go ahead and use
the 14-inch chassis and then maybe
remove some of the options we've seen
lately when apple has released their new
macbooks they've raised the price when
they released the imax they also raised
the price and they're adding new
features they're making them nicer but
in general prices are going up and apple
definitely cannot release the same
macbook with just a new chip and raise
the price more so and that also will
affect the redesigned macbook air that's
going to come out in the fall because if
this machine is still priced at 12.99
it'll be tough for them to price the new
macbook
much higher than this or even the same
price it has always been lower than the
macbook pro so if this first scenario
does come to be true
i guess the benefit is for apple it will
kind of guide more people to spend more
money if they want the new redesign with
the notch with the pro motion display
the sd card reader hdmi with magsafe it
really is going to push people to spend
more money it's going to make that 2 000
price point seem like a better value and
along with that if the scenario comes
true then the leaks from mark german
that came out previously will also be
correct but he said that it could be the
old design but without the touch bar
which this new leak is saying the touch
part is still here now scenario number
two could be an m2 chip coming out but
with the 14 inch new design from the
macbooks that came out last fall this is
personally what we were expecting and
what we think would be better because
it's going to future proof this laptop
and they could price it at 1500 dollars
and remove some of the features that
come with the 2 000 14 inch macbook pro
it would be very similar to that but it
would come with slower ssds so instead
of up to 7
400 megabit per second it will stick
with the standard kind of 3 000 megabyte
per second range it's going to have
slower ram it's going to come with less
ram instead of 16 gig down to 8 also
half the ssd 256 gigabyte to start and
it would also likely come with worse
speakers compared to the six speaker
setup if we look into the past this is
exactly what happened with the base
macbook pro it would look very similar
spec wise but when we actually did tests
the ssd would be slower some other
components would be slower and even
though speakers weren't advertised they
were significantly
worse sounding and then the higher end
model so you did get the extra when you
paid for it and with the previous 13
inch macbook pros once you upgraded the
256 gigabyte and 16 gigs of ram from the
base model you are only one hundred
dollars away from the higher end for
thunderbolt port model and in this
scenario if they do price at 1500 that
will result to the same exact kind of
layout that they have done for many
years now the third scenario could be
that it will be very similar to the one
i just talked about but they could also
take away some of the ports for example
they could take it with the hdmi they
could take away the sd card reader and
take away one of the thunderbolt ports
so cleave that side clean and then on
the other side you still have two ports
there like we did in the past and then
you also have the magsafe charger as
well so you kind of have a little bit
more options than the previous 13 inch
macbook pro now of course that would
suck but like apple's done in the past
the base macbook pros did have more
limitations and less ports than if you
bought the more expensive one but you
guys let me know what are your thoughts
do you think they will really release
the same 13-inch macbook pro with the
touch bar but just with the m2 chip and
if so is that enough to get you to
actually buy one of those machines
instead of spending more on the 2 000 14
inch or waiting for the fall for a
redesigned macbook air i want to hear
your opinions down below click that
circle above to help us reach 1 million
subscribers thanks for watching this has
been max check out one of those great
videos right over there and i'll see you
in the next video
[Music]